the conjuring 3 is chock full of easter
eggs from secret annabelle and nun
connections to classic horror movie
tributes and clues to the movie's big
twists and reveals
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing all the things you
might have missed and the devil made me
do it and explaining how the movie
connects to the wider conjuring universe
spoilers ahead of course so take care
the creepy annabelle doll is an iconic
figure in the conjuring franchise and
the devil made me do it expands on the
story behind the satanic cult
disciples of the ram from the first
annabelle movie where one of the cult's
members annabelle higgins murdered her
adoptive parents before going on to
attack mia and john form
in the conjuring three ed and lorraine
meet father castner
a priest who investigated and exposed
the disciples of the ram
kasna tells the warrens they shouldn't
underestimate the power of these
satanists and when ed asks him why
someone would target an innocent child
the why is irrelevant the wise counter
to everything that the satanist
stands for his soul aim is chaos echoes
what detective clarkin told the forms
and annabelle about what he'd learned
about the cult
they did this to prove their devotion of
sort of violence for violence sake
while researching the disciples of the
ram castner collected various occult
objects and books and kept them locked
in his basement room
similar to the warrens artifact room
where they keep the annabelle doll
and many cursed and haunted objects from
their investigations
and his answer to lorraine's suggestion
that he should burn all of it
i've thought of that but i felt it was
safer to keep them locked
i like taking guns off the streets is
similar to what ed
said in the conjuring when we were first
introduced to the warrens artifact room
why not just
throw him in an incinerator well that
would only destroy the vessel sometimes
it's better to keep the genie in the
bottle it's kind of like keeping guns
off the street and there's another
conjuring easter egg and the devil made
me do it as the parents the family from
the first movie's haunted house a name
dropped when the warrens received some
get well soon flowers
look what the parent family sent that
was sweet of them the demon nun valach
was the main antagonist in the conjuring
ii and although she didn't make a direct
appearance and the devil made me do it
after arnie's been possessed there's a
creepy little nun figurine in his
bedroom at the boarding kennels
also in the movie's epilogue scenes is
the creepy painting of the nun that came
alive in the second conjuring movie and
which has now been moved into the
artifact room for safe keeping
however notice how the painting is kept
framed in the shot as ed brings the
occultist curse chalice into the room
reminding us that ballack is still the
principal villain of the franchise and
lurking in the background
just like annabelle who is also
carefully framed and shot when the
camera switches angles
by the way there was also another little
nod to the conjuring too when lorraine
sees an upside down cross while
searching for the occultist location
referencing the chilling scene where
janet sees all the crosses in a room
slowly turn upside down
a similar moment happens in the opening
of the nun where a crucifix slowly
inverts as valak emerges from the depths
of the abbey and in the conjuring
universe inverted crosses are a demonic
indicator
such as the one that appears on
frenchie's neck and the nun and which
the warrens talk about during their
presentation about possession
and like that an upside-down cross has
started to appear from within his body
balak of course got her own evil
backstory in the nun movie and a
connection
with the conjuring three that you might
not have noticed is that one of the
occultist victims jessica is played by
actress ingrid bisu
who also starred as sister oanna in the
demon nun's origin story
the fact that these two characters are
played by the same actor
could throw up some interesting theories
about the conjuring universe
especially given that spoiler alert for
the nun
sister owana was already dead in that
movie
just before arnie murders bruno take a
closer look at the two posters on the
wall behind his landlord
first of all there's black sabbath's
iconic album cover featuring a
mysterious even maybe witch-like woman
a reference to the occultist who is
manipulating arnie in this very moment
and then there's ella fitzgerald's mac
the knife the famous song about a
legendary criminal which foreshadows her
auntie is about to pick up a knife and
become a notorious killer
there are a number of books you can see
behind ed and lorraine in the office of
arnie's defense attorney but want of
particular relevance
is jonathan strange and mr norrell by
susanna clarke
because the novel is set in an alternate
history of 19th century england
much like how the third conjuring movie
puts its own fictionalized spin on
real-life events
giving us an alternate history of the
trial of arnie johnson
in the conjuring 3 director michael
chavez wanted to pay homage to several
iconic horror movies
so at the beginning of the film when
father gordon arrives in a cab at the
glatzel family home with a hat coat and
briefcase
the mist and black silhouette figure
that he forms is a homage to the scene
where father marin arrives in the
exorcist
other references to the iconic film
include how david wurtz speckled blue
pajamas during the exorcism like reagan
and how arnie sacrifices himself for
david by inviting the demon into his
body
similar to father karass and the
exorcist although the outcome of course
is different
chavez also says that the figure of
arnie appearing in a window as father
gordon arrives is a deliberate reference
to janet lee seeing mother in the window
when she first
arrives at the bates motel in psycho and
the shot of david being showered with
blood inside the bathtub may also be a
nod to the iconic shower scene in that
same film
the waterbed scene and the devil made me
do it is also another deliberate homage
by the director to one of the first
horror movies he ever saw a nightmare on
elm street 4 the dream master
so when david senses a face appearing to
him from inside the mattress
it's similar to how joey in elm street 4
sees a model appear to him inside the
bed
and the hand bursting out of the
mattress to grab david
is a nod to how freddy krueger jumps out
of the waterbed to attack joey
when ed is possessed by the occultist
while he's searching for lorraine in the
tunnels the shots of him holding a
hammer and dragging his injured leg
along are a little hat tip to the
showdown at the end of the shining where
jack torrance limps along with an axe
and is like ed being influenced by an
evil entity
there's an annabelle easter egg via the
name of the palmeri funeral home which
ed and lorraine visit to try and make a
connection with the occultists through
jessica's dead body
palmeri was the name of the pasadena
apartment complex that mia and john
moved to in the first annabelle you're
the lieutenant saint
paul it's also the name of mary ellen's
crush and annabelle comes home
bob paul murray i'm scared balls how you
doing
there's also a visual shout out to
annabelle comes home by the creepy
colour wheel that's been added to the
warren's artifact room
the wheel terrorized judy warren in that
movie when it manifested the many forms
annabelle has taken in the conjuring
franchise
i like your dolls although i prefer
previous conjuring villains like valak
and bathsheba
the occultist has some interesting
paranormal powers such as the ability to
manipulate her victims from afar
and create optical illusions to trick
them into acts they wouldn't do
she made arnie johnson think his
landlord was some kind of hellish
creature attacking him
and also made ed warren momentarily
think lorraine was an evil monster
the occultist had a copy of lorraine
appear in front of her mirroring her
movements exactly this trippy moment was
foreshadowed at the beginning of the
movie during david's exorcism when the
camera drew was filming with was knocked
over
as the camera continued to film it was
pointed towards a tv that was screening
the live recording
causing an image of the screen to
replicate itself endlessly
this was a neat visual piece of
foreshadowing that was originally going
to lead into an even more trippy
sequence than we got in the final movie
in the trailers for the film you can see
a deleted scene where lorraine sees many
copies of herself
replicating endlessly in a spiral of
sorts into the distance
and if you want to learn more about that
as well as all the other deleted scenes
including a cut
post-credits scene i'll be talking about
all that in my next conjuring video
i'll add a link for you to watch it here
and in the video description as soon as
it's ready
so what did you think of the devil made
me do it and how does it compare to your
other favorite movies in this franchise
let me know in the comments below if you
enjoyed this leave a thumbs up and a
share is also hugely appreciated
tap left for my full conjuring universe
playlist or tap right to learn all about
the secret zombies in the army of the
dead their alien origins and hidden
timeline twist
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers